in the daily mail inflation hits highest
rate since 2008. the price of milk bread
meat and energy rose 4.2 percent this
year as the economy recovers from covert
oh is that what they're saying oh but is
it rebounding too fast
i love this thing where they're they're
starting they're claiming inflation
isn't actually that high it's an
illusion because it was frozen last year
because of covet and now it's just
coming back it's all coming back no it
isn't people don't have jobs they're not
working what do you mean it's coming
back there's signs across the board
people like i don't want to work here
i'm not going to work there there's 8.1
million job openings and they could only
fill 266 000 wow you call that
recovering from covid no the economy is
in flames and joe biden's like come on
man do more uh nobody should work uh you
know
workers of the world unite
take take money from the rich the thing
about inflation is it's not a static
number it didn't like land here and this
is where it's at it's a momentous force
so it's passing through 4.2 percent
where does it say the number four point
two percent that's passing through that
on its way to another number it's moving
there was uh something that i was told
earlier that there were a bunch of boxes
that were very heavy for you that
arrived that would be flour how much uh
30 40 pounds four or four pounds of
flour something like that that's that's
no 160 pounds
170 pounds why did you buy that because
you can freeze it and it's available
to get it now before
there's a run on it i have a really
important side note about this do you
want to know who moved these boxes of
flowers
this afternoon it was lydia lydia
thank you lydia there's pumpernickel
flower
what are you doing
i parked in the parking lot and walked
right past ten boxes
oh that was a pizza sorry that was beans
in our eyes so we're getting prepped so
yeah we are but i do want to clarify
yeah it sounds like a lot that ian
bought but there's what like 14 people
that come through here
yeah and so
we're not
we're not actually buying bread from the
store we don't do that ian just starts a
loaf of bread with fresh ingredients
everything's so good you got about five
or six days out of it if everybody eats
it with moderation
i challenge you to ditch the bread maker
my friend i did the first four or five
years i made bread was that without
bread maker i'd be hands on the bread
using my own body heat to warm it up as
you press into it definitely but it
would take two to three hours it's a lot
of fun you gotta let it rise and do this
thing on 20 on election night 2016 i
made baguettes that night throughout the
election man
well so so we're not doing a segment on
bread oh sorry we're just talking about
inflation inflation and and panic buying
yeah so
there you go i don't i don't think it's
fair to say it's panic buying when
everyone decides to go get gas at the
same time
it's not a panic if you're like oh man
what's going on news i'm at half a tank
i better you know top off because i got
work tomorrow common sense that's just
like normal things but there are videos
of people doing there's a video of like
a guy with with a bunch of plastic bags
full of gasoline in his trunk you see
this i did tied off and then and then
what is it the product consumer safety
you know twitter was like please do not
fill up plastic bags with gasoline i can
confirm i did not panic by the 150
pounds of flour okay i just saw that it
was available and thought what a boon
what a luxury that i have as a human to
have access to 150 pounds of organic
white flour i want it now i can freeze
it it'll last for years and years get it
and then i realized after well if
there's a panic run those things become
you can only buy four you can only buy
20 pounds of it now so i'm glad i got it
now so that's kind of like panic buying
dude but i did i wasn't in a panic when
i bought it i just thought no no no
that's the issue is that
when the prices start skyrocketing and
inflation is going up people are like
okay look i got 10 bucks right now
tomorrow it's gonna have the buying
power of five bucks then i mean honestly
the ten bucks today is the buying power
of like what like less than a cent the
ten bucks is like borderline worthless
compared to 100 years ago so people are
like i better spend the money now
because
you know it's not i'm not going to buy
anything with it tomorrow so then
everybody says all right bread milk
energy so what are people doing they're
buying tons of stuff this causes product
shortages and it causes more inflation
it works both ways too imagine you're a
guy that's got a warehouse full of stuff
you can sell today for 10 or tomorrow
for 12.
there was a craigslist post that went
viral where somebody was like a couple
weeks ago i bought a bunch of gas for
you know my machines or whatever 16 a
gallon come by and i'll i'll top you off
or something like that people are
hoarding gas now and trying to exploit
the crisis because sometimes people a
lot of people are just bad people you
know
is that is that a bad person or are they
providing liquidity in a time of crisis
which is a service that people want
because they're freely engaging in the
buying and selling of that commodity
which they could not get anywhere else
except for that price this is the same
concept behind uber surge pricing which
i fully support i've gotten totally
screwed by it i've paid 200 for a 20 cab
ride before because there's no other
cars and it was a surge time but i paid
for it because why it's not the only way
to get the car i i wouldn't say it's the
exactly the same thing right going to a
gas station when you when you know
there's gonna be a crisis and buying by
buying as much as possible to then
resell it right off right off the bat
i'm not a fan of in some areas people
complain about uh price uh um gouging on
like water right there'll be a storm and
then someone will be like five dollars
for a bottle of water and i'm like
that's fantastic you know why
if you buy a bunch of water and drive it
into a disaster you're taking risk
you're buying things you can sell for
what you want to sell for that's
different that's the same as the guy no
it is who took it back to his house he
took on the risk that would be going to
the gas station right before the
hurricane it's buying all their water
and then standing outside being like now
it's five bucks that's not providing a
service and alleviating any tensions
that's exploiting the crisis if you're
bringing so when we saw people got they
got in trouble because they brought
water into disaster areas and sold it
for like five bucks a bottle and i'm
like there'd be no water there somebody
decided to drive into the disaster
taking risks to bring water to these
people it costs money
taking taking water from the store and
then going outside and doubling the cost
of it you're just exploiting people who
are in a crisis sure i'm not sure fine i
guess if you're a capitalist you're
probably alive but that guy with the gas
could have been taking it a hundred
miles away to a place where they didn't
have any gas you don't know that we just
don't see seeing videos of people
filling up like laundry tubs with
gasoline look as somebody who went to
the gas station twice today to make sure
i had a full tank to drive round trip
all the way out here and make sure i can
take my kids around school tomorrow and
whatever
i like was thinking maybe i should have
trash bags well yes in my car too
sure because because if i can't take my
kids places or i can't pick them up then
i don't get to see my children
you're not filling up trash bags of gas
to then resell for five times the price
at the same location okay you gotta
wonder when does it become predatory i
guess because there's nothing wrong with
marking up your your product in if
someone needs it you know like if the
the story of the umbrella salesman that
will sell the umbrellas for a dollar
until it rains and then they're twenty
dollars each or ten dollars each that's
fine and they still sell all the
umbrellas that's fine um
same with water when there's a crisis
you sell the water for a markup of 500
whatever i'm saying that if you walked
into walgreens and bought all their
umbrellas and then stood outside because
you knew it was going to rain and then
sold them for double the cost i think
that's screwed up yeah that's actually
illegal in the stock market to buy out
an entire service and then relist it at
a higher price i'm just saying like you
you know that
like you're taking advantage of people
you're not providing anything for
society you're not producing you're
literally standing in front of the store
selling what you just bought and
stripping money away from people because
they're in need i'm not a fan of that
i'm not i'm not a fan of people who
produce nothing and then can take away
from people who do work i think it's
funny because i don't i don't think that
should be like a left position because
i'm pretty sure trump supporters are
very much in favor of protecting workers
rights and their right to own property
and and freely trading all that stuff
really trade and so i'm not saying they
can't do it i'm just saying i think it's
screwed up i wouldn't do it i don't
think it's illegal to resell gas for
like you know what it was like three
bucks a gallon five dollars you know uh
five times as much 16 a gallon i think
that's screwed up to do yeah i think
it's taken it's exploiting people but
i if it's illegal it's illegal i guess i
don't know i'm just saying if you if he
brought the gasoline to some place and
he was like look i had a tank for this
reason i'm gonna bring it into this area
if you bought a bunch of gas in west
virginia where there's gas and drove it
into north carolina and sold it for 16 a
gallon i got no problem you're bringing
a product to people who are in desperate
need and you're taking a risk you can
charge whatever you want for it it's
yours if you're buying it from the gas
station and then going all right now if
you want guests
i got it all i'm like dude screw you you
know that's messed up i think michael
brown was doing that with cigarettes
part of why the cops he was on lucy's
different so he like would go into the
store buy a pack for 12 bucks and then
he'd come out and sell him for a dollar
a piece is that what he was doing that's
not michael brown michael brown was
trying to was trying to steal cigarillos
or something you're talking about eric
garner oh god eric garner people look
not everybody wants a full pack of
cigarettes right so if imagine this
imagine if you had a pack of cigarettes
and i was like yo can i get a sick off
you and you were like uh give me a
dollar i bet okay yeah that's what he
was doing but he was standing right
outside the store where he bought them
and the stores don't like to tell lucy's
that way because then people won't buy a
pack of cigarettes but
but it's it's not the same thing he's
not exploiting crisis he's exploiting in
that instance that people don't want a
full pack of cigarettes so i get it it's
a nuisance to the business but it's not
the same thing especially if you're
right outside the door if he bought all
of the cigarettes and then when people
were like i need a series like too bad
they're all mine now you got to pay
double plus you need a license to sell
tobacco um i don't know about gas it's
different or water i don't think it's
different
it's it's
water someone going into a place and
taking
so that no one else can buy it and then
demanding more from other people age old
the richest can go and buy up all the
resources and then resell them for more
expensive and that's been outlawed i'm i
don't know the exact laws but i know
that that's not if you call it free
trade but that means it's definitely
there's oversight it doesn't mean anyone
can sell it it's called a monopoly
yeah you're not supposed to be able to
have monopolies yes it's called monopoly
when you buy up all the stuff and can
raise the price because there's no other
competitors in your market and when
there's chaos and the lack of oversight
because of disaster then
how do you
how do you track it you really
it's challenging that's a challenge well
you know what would happen to that guy
if it's like the only reason people
either do this because the government
protects them that's that's the reality
do you know you know imagine if there
was no police and some guy pulls up to a
gas station and fills up you know a
bunch of five-gallon tanks then he says
he puts it up and it's like out of order
and then he turns around with a smile on
his face and says
it was three bucks now it's 16. you know
what's going to happen they're going to
walk up and they're going to take it
from him you can't get his ass kicked
yeah they wouldn't i mean he'd be like
hey don't take my guess and they'd be
like you can't do anything about it
thanks for the free guess
if that that's what so the government
protects that guy when he does it that's
the problem because if it was truly just
a more libertarian or free market yeah
that guy would be able to do that they'd
be like i ain't playing that game with
you
but the police would be there in two
seconds to defend him and his property
and so it's a hybrid system that allows
him to exploit people this way
only about a social worker to distribute
all the gasoline equally amongst all of
the little birdies in the nest hey man
first come first serve you go to the gas
station you got cash you can buy it you
fill up your tank that makes sense i
think if you pull up and you got a 10
gallon real red canister and you're like
look i'm filling it up because i got a
lawnmower or whatever i think that's
fine too and people are freaking out
over that there's stories where like a
woman you know out here went to a gas
station and she had she filled up her
car and then filled up like a five
gallon thing and people were screaming
you're hoarding don't steal our gas and
she's like i got a lawnmower this is so
dumb
are people yelling at the guys in the
suvs who have a 25 gallon tank and just
saying hey okay to the fiesta with the
12 gallon tank right the yelling at
those guys this whole thing is dumb the
whole thing is but but filling up like
10 tanks and then being like now it's 16
that's something else
so i kind of i'm kind of like maybe we
need to get rid of the police in that
regard too because then people wouldn't
do it because they'd be worried about
their neighbors right now the cops
protect them if you actually had to
worry about upsetting offending or or
wronging your neighbors law is
less relevant
what's more relevant is whether or not
you're being a good person unless you
have like body guards and a bunch of
weapons and then you decide to charge 30
a gallon for the gas that you just
bought up yeah it's still wrong uh 50
people if there's a hundred cars yeah
how many bodyguards are gonna need to
stop a hundred angry people when you
take all their gas away seven that are
fully armed nah it's not going to happen
if they're not armed they can't do
anything they have an armed force and
you've got armed populations in a lot of
these states a lot of them so you can
have a bodyguard but if you start
stealing the gas from 100 people waiting
dude if i'm waiting online stealing it
if you buy it yeah
i'm sorry i don't i don't agree you just
got there first
advocate here i'm talking about a guy
who's filling up 16 tanks you know and
taking all the capitalism no i think it
is illegal to do stuff like that right
and so the point is in a community
without protection of the government
that wouldn't happen a guy's gonna get
out of his car and he's gonna have a gun
too you know it's a it's it's up in the
air what would happen because it might
not happen there might be like hey you
can't do that to us this is our society
or it might be like he's more powerful
and he's like i can do whatever i want
to you this is my society and then
they're like uh i have nothing i'll work
for you right we have a second amendment
people in these states have guns you can
have 10 bodyguards but if 100 people go
out of their cars and they're screaming
i don't think those bodyguards might
stick around for much longer
it's not so simple man the only reason
people are awaited people are able to do
these things is because the government
protects them when they do it
otherwise they would be terrified of the
riotous mob that's coming to basically
take their stuff i don't i think it's
more who has the the most force not the
government almost like like if someone
back in the day had all the money and
wanted to buy up all the resources and
hire all the military and there was no
government then they would be the new
government
sort of in a lot of ways but they still
deal with with death and conflict from
people who resist now there's a monopoly
on violence the government has and they
allow people to do this stuff and
regular citizens won't do anything about
it because they know they can't because
the cops will come and shut it down and
the courts will shut it down if it was
just a system where people were like
don't wrong me and i won't wrong you and
there was a shared moral framework we
wouldn't be dealing with that kind of
stuff
people get like shrunk up in cities and
it's different you know we we need a
rule of law we need uh fair and just
courts
now what we're dealing with is everybody
who hates everybody else or doesn't care
completely indifferent so they're like i
don't know you i don't care about you i
don't care if you're sick i don't care
if you need insulin i'm gonna take and
i'm gonna keep so now everyone's just
everyone every man for himself and you
can't you can't function that way it's
funny because
the left are collectivists
but
they don't actually care about the true
collective like the country the
community so they claim to be but
they're only collectivists with their
tribe who try to seize power from others
whereas conservatives are collectivists
in the sense they believe in the nation
not every conservative i guess but most
conservatives are nationalists and so
that's about we as a country working
together agreeing on certain things
functioning together having certain
respect for each other and letting
people live
the problem is the culture war is two
different moral frameworks the left
doesn't care about anything i like the
individual versus collective mentality
because if i care about you and you and
you i care about us as a collective
because i care about the individuals but
if i just care about the collective you
become like nameless faces to me and all
i care about is what we do as a group
that's the danger of collectivism and
then they think you should be punished
because someone in the house did
something
it's the sins of the father i suppose
i don't know look man inflation's going
up
so
we're buying bitcoin i guess i think
yeah the only we got a gas shortage we
got food shortage we got all kinds of
shortages the only thing we know but
shortage of is dollars
dollars out there
chasing everything everywhere and you
know the sad scary part is
is that mmt modern monetary theory is
making headway into the government and
somebody's somewhere up there right now
is saying oh inflation's going up well
the way mt described or prescribes to
deal with inflation how you do that
raise taxes baby that's what they want
to do yeah raising taxes is how you
control inflation according to modern
monetary theory so keep an eye out for
that guys after all this
skyrocketing gas prices skyrocketing
food prices inflation everywhere and
guess what they're gonna do to to fix it
raise your taxes on top of it yeah
because they have to compensate for the
fact that printing money like crazy they
got to soak it up out of the economy yep
yeah the us is rotten uh
it's buy bitcoin it's rotted to the core
and it's it's falling apart and it's
getting worse every day and the scary
thing is watching what we talked about
last year happening right now it's all
happening
we were all saying the bill will come
due on the mass printing of this money
yeah and i said look if we printed the
money and gave gave it to everybody at
least we're borrowing from ourselves if
they were like we're gonna you know
three trillion dollars and it goes
evenly amongst all americans that's free
tax-free to engage in commerce i'm like
it's gonna cause inflation but at least
we're borrowing the money from ourselves
the problem there is a lot of people who
don't work people who do but
there's a pandemic and we agree we're
going to work with each other and we're
a country that must survive and work
together i accept these things they
didn't do that though
they were giving it to big businesses i
first came on the show one february of
2010 january 2020 january 2020 yeah and
uh we've been talking about this we've
been talking about what happened through
corona we've been talking about what
would happen if biden took office we've
been talking about all these things and
all the things that we talked about are
actually happening and worse and i still
can't believe it even though we talked
about it predicted it said it was going
to happen and now it's actually worse i
should have bought bitcoin it's the
beauty of physics man you you calculate
where the ball is going to be when you
throw it at that velocity in that
direction and it lands there and that's
basically what we did with this
economy i mean it's it's
blatantly obvious that if you print
money in may of 2020 that in february of
2021 you're going to see an inflation
spec thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 p.m where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you